don't you be touching my junk alright
folks
firstly I'm sorry for the lack of a
video last week I shot one on my iPhone
edited it twice and there were some
glitch in the sequence that I couldn't
work out every single gene y ASET the
Apple Store couldn't help me so I had to
scrap it and I'm using a webcam this
week but keep checking back there will
be videos every Thursday and I'll be
increasing the quality with HD cameras
bringing back characters new equipment
so stay tuned also before I start I know
a few of you are noticing the little
mouse I have under my eye here don't
worry it's not what you think I just got
punched in the face look that I
converted to Islam and gave her a fresh
one which brings me to this week's hot
topic the TSA and naked people I'm sure
you all know about the body scanners at
airport security and in recent weeks
people have been upset by the thorough
pat downs one gentleman even made the
news by refusing to allow his junk to be
touched you know I hate to say it but
this is a topic where I part ways with a
lot of my libertarian and conservative
brethren I don't really care if keeping
people from blowing me up means that
they catch a glimpse of my zub then so
be it
have a gander a couple of laughs at its
termite like stature and then send me on
my merry way to be honest it's worse for
them because I've got the fat going on
and not the visceral fat but the sub
contain iasts gelatinous fat I'm liking
to me but more of a shape-shifter if you
will like that gallon not species only
I'm not a chick nor attractive now I
don't have a problem with practices like
this if I believe that the TSA would be
keeping us safe why because keeping
citizens safe is one of the few
legitimate roles of government remember
the hockey referee analogy that I've
used in videos and columns past keep the
players safe meaning us the people from
both inside and outside threats make
sure to keep the pace of the game
otherwise you should keep the whistle in
your pocket but the key word here is if
I do have a problem with giving this
kind of power to a government
bureaucracy riddled with political
correctness I do have a problem with
patting down a three-year-old but
according to the Council on
american-islamic relations Muslim women
should be exempt meaning no searches
from anything more than a head to neck
are you kidding me listen I wouldn't put
it past an Islamic terrorist to use a
three-year-old as a mule but if we're
not going to be searching the people who
are throwing up red flags with giant
loud whistles then there's no point to
it in the first place
we should be tearing a page from
Israel's book an incredibly effective
book might I add so what what are you
think Stephen that we should be
profiling yes absolutely we should
profile early and often I say if we're
going to allow the government to expand
in power regarding security we need to
take off the harness of political
correctness and allow them to be
effective this should either be done
properly or not at all well what do you
folks think let me know and I will be
back next Thursday but for now I've got
to go smack my Dame around but only
lightly come on she's got to learn
boundaries
[Music]